kovat 19 response team says it is  beefing up its disease outbreak plan as  more places open up now this comes as  the state is starting to see an increase  in cases the fourth biggest increase  since the pandemic was declared here in  Nevada we just mentioned that now an  increase like this was expected that's  what health officials say the response  team is adding positions and hundreds of  people to the contact tracing team  trying to minimize the spread  health officials say if everyone does  their part we can keep the disease at  bay and so he's reminded you that social  distancing and face mask even homemade  face masks are the way to stop the  spread of this infection with the most  current data still too early to tell if  we're going to see a second major wave  of the corona virus state local health  officials though are continuing to  monitor the progress of the disease